[Music]
[Applause]
seven-time nba all-star he won the
scoring title twice
tracy mcgrady hall of famer joining us
on behalf of the ones basketball league
first ever elite competition he created
celebrates the most skilled one-on-one
players on the planet which we'll talk
about coming up here in a moment tracy
good to talk to you again how are you
you're doing well dan how about
yourselves no complaints i know you're
turning 43 in a couple of weeks
can you still dunk
oh absolutely yeah i still can do it
could you still one hand
well in today's game yeah
three-point line yes absolutely just
back up threes
do you have any grudges still from guys
you played against
no
no
not at all it wasn't that serious
oh really well i thought you know back
in the
you know 90s
like guys didn't like each other and i
would i would have thought maybe that
would carry over and you know that i
mike doesn't like isaiah thomas you know
well i was i mean there there was a lot
of
bad blood between chicago bulls and the
bad boys
you know rumors of mike keeping isaiah
off the olympic team like you know i
mean
a lot of things went on in that in that
era in that series that those guys
played against and uh it created a lot
of bad blood between you know
mike
pip isaiah
all those boys i didn't know that you
thought you were going to be traded to
the bulls
was that draft night
that was draft night so
it's f it's 12 o'clock
draft night my agent calls me and
he tells me that i need to get dressed
because they have a secret location
for me to go and take a physical
so i went to a clinic they had this back
entrance that we went through
um no one saw me come in took a physical
and
it was crazy
at the time i thought
when it didn't go down for all these
years i thought michael jordan was the
one that
really put a nail into that that trade
not happening
but i just got word it was jerry
ronsdorf that did that
also the the owner what was the reason
why so you were going to be traded for
pippin
yes which
i i
jerry krause had an obsession with me
right even in
when i was a free agent um after my
three years in toronto
he was still trying to recruit me and
make me a chicago bull
so
did you check with michael the story and
michael said that he didn't nix the
trade
no no i haven't had an opportunity to
talk to mike about that i would love to
get his opinion on that
but
it was a real thing
to get me out of bed at 12 o'clock it
had to be a real
uh also you weren't all in on lebron
when you first faced him were you like
did you see that this guy is going to be
the chosen one he's going to be one of
the great players of all time
i knew he had the potential i didn't
think he was going to be where he is
today
no
i i didn't think he was going to have
that type of career i mean i knew the
kid was good he was very talented but
to think that
he would be
one of the the greatest
arguably the greatest to play the game
no not at the time no you don't see that
but you guys faced each other
orlando and the cavs on christmas day
yeah that was bad he was a rookie yeah
he was a rookie at the time
and but
he was the kid was good the kid at the
time i'm calling the kid because he was
18 years old at the time
um but he was he was really good
but
even then i still didn't think you know
he was going to be
arguably the greatest player of all time
no i i didn't see that but also you put
up i think 41. so you're probably saying
hey
let me tell you something
you got to go through me before you you
know become the chosen one well he was
in the eastern conference and i was in
the east um at the time i was on a very
bad team
very bad team
with orlando because we traded away all
of our good players mike miller was gone
daryl armstrong was gone
grant hill was still hurt so
um
i was my team wasn't that good i didn't
have no room to even brag individually
yes i was really good but as a team i i
had no room to to talk did you think you
were better than him
when then yeah
oh absolutely yeah of course okay
all right i'm just
when did you realize lebron was better
than you
never i i
why would i say someone is better than
me then
okay look like i'm an nba player too
you think you're better than lebron
do i i can't sit here and say i'm better
than lebron is arguably the greatest of
all time
no
i didn't have a better career than
lebron james no absolutely not yeah
i that's i can't even don't even put me
in that same
you know breadth of what this guy has
accomplished i mean it's
it's amazing to me that in year 19 he's
still doing what he's doing yeah but
there had to be a point where you go uh
oh
he you know he's he's
he's moving ahead of me
well by the time
by the time i i felt like bronn was the
best in the league i was washed up oh
right
i was watched
what was the biggest challenge you come
out of high school is the bigger
challenge on the quarter off the court
the biggest challenge is off the court
there's a lot of things you have to deal
with you know uh when you're coming out
of high school
you know you're not
you you have to make sure that you
surround yourself with the right team
that has your best interest because of
one the economics that you're coming
into
and the the people that are out there to
latch on to you to take advantage of you
you got to be cognizant
there's just a lot that comes into play
and
you know from from how lebron has laid
the blueprint is
really a lot of these guys should follow
i mean it's perfect what this guy was
able to accomplish coming out of high
school and i'm not even
you know uh
downplaying what i was able to
accomplish because i'm doing quite well
for myself but if you look at lebron and
and how he set his self up and his his
friends this circle of friends and what
they're doing now is phenomenal
what's the worst money you ever spent
um
early in your career
i think just the toys you know just the
material things you know the like what
the lamborghinis yeah the lamborghinis
the ferraris
you know wait wait did you say plural
lamborghinis
lamborghini oh only one oh only one okay
yeah and ferrari
i also owned a plane
i bought my own plane but i actually um
you know i i made profit off of that but
you know just when i was younger man
just
the the the toys the materialistic
things that as i got older i don't even
care for those things anymore i have two
cars
and
what are they
just a range rover in the f-150
and the reason i bought my f1 because
during the pandemic i was going fishing
every day
and i didn't want to use my range rover
to put all that
[Laughter]
f-150 talking to tracy mcgrady uh he and
yao ming a formidable duo in houston i
think for six years
yao ming is a big man like there are a
lot of big men
that's a big
big man
but is he bigger than shaq
he's he's taller and leaner than shaq
he's not bigger than shaq
but
it's
to see a 7-5
guy every day
you would think you'll get
you know immune to that i never did yeah
i i couldn't believe how big this guy
was every single day i'm looking at like
just shaking my head
you're a massive man did you ever dunk
on him
i don't think i got a chance to no did
you because in practice in practice we
were always on the same team did you
dunk on shaq
no one done
[Laughter]
he wouldn't let you
no
no that that was one thing that he would
he was not going to allow and
you know he had his
set of guys that he wouldn't foul hard
and i was one of those guys
but if i was trying to if i would have
tried to dunk on shaq i would have
gotten fouled really hard wait explain
that to me he had a list of guys that he
would go okay i'm not going to hurt you
this time yeah he had a list of guys
that he wouldn't foul hard
to be
you know a little tap
um
enough for you to fill it but
i was on that list i think hey i was on
that list vince was on that list i think
um i don't know i don't quite know who
else
i just know i didn't get the hard fouls
i got you dunking on matumbo here
i just saw that
i was just with him this weekend and we
were arguing about that oh
what's there to argue about
he claims i only dunked on him once but
i told him it was multiple times that i
dunked on him
but you know did he do the finger thing
to you
he did he did he did he did the finger
wave to me
and i i dunked on him
um
i dunked on it one time and i gave it
back to him oh
but yeah it was always argument and i
dunked on him in practice when he was my
teammate with the rockets
great guy though oh he's great he's so
much fun to be around
he is so so much fun yeah he's a
character
uh tracy's joining us on behalf of one's
basketball league the obl
how did you come up with the concept of
well who can get involved in this
so it's it's
so we don't want nba players but if you
have
less than two years of experience of mba
experience then
you can get in but it's 18 and up
and
dan i want those guys
that
you know have
you know they played probably played
college ball didn't get an opportunity
to play nba or go across seas and play
basketball or maybe they did go across
seas but
these guys still have
what it takes to play elite basketball
and they have a passion for it
and maybe when they was younger you know
uh along their journey
their basketball journeys something
happened in their life to where they had
to deviate off course
or they didn't just get the opportunity
they took they was told eight they're
not good enough
to me
there are a lot of guys out here
that
when it comes to one-on-one basketball
is some of the greatest talent you ever
see
and i'm talking about on the levels of
kyrie irving
a kd
a james harden luca like these guys are
out here on these blocks in these
streets playing pickup ball
and i i built this for those guys and so
far we've
went to houston
and atlanta
and it's been some pretty damn good
basketball games of one-on-one that you
know we have witnessed
best one-on-one player of all time in
your opinion is
um
from an nba perspective i have to say
between michael jordan and kobe bryant
as far as their skill set
i don't i don't know if there's
a lot of difference between those two
offensively
is there
um
i think kobe is more skilled
i i my opinion i think kobe is more
skilled
mj didn't shoot the three ballets
as much so
i give kobe the advantage on that
because he did shoot the three ball yeah
um
both of them have impeccable footwork
we know what their mind is
uh they have an array of moves but i
just
there's just something about
watching mike and watching kobe and it's
like
i'm seeing we see mike and kobe but i'm
seeing a little bit more in terms of the
skill
just a little bit
more i'm just surprised that jordan
didn't go for 80 points in a game you
know kobe goes for 81 against toronto
do you think we'll see a 100 point score
again
no okay i i can't no i can't see what
about 80
i could see 80 again by who
i i don't think is anybody in today's
game but it's i think somebody can come
i mean devin booker has 70. yeah
he was close
but you had 62 against washington
i had 62 missed nine of my last 10 shots
and missed nine free throws wow
yeah say that again you had a bad game i
had a very bad guy you got 62 and had a
bad game i had a bad game
i really did i could have made history
that night who was guarding you that
night who wasn't guarding you that night
the washington wizards was trying to
guard me that night yeah
that's just one of those where you just
go man it feels good and you just it's
it felt
i mean it felt good but it didn't feel
great
right if that means anything it felt
good
but it didn't feel great i had i've i've
had games where i felt great like i
couldn't miss anything like free throws
anything
that game was just
had a little rhythm i didn't have no
rhythm at the free throw line because i
missed nine free throws and that was
uncharacteristic of me i shot 80 percent
or something like that
i was very uncasual
it's great to talk to you you look great
and sound great good luck with uh one's
basketball league and uh is there more
information that people can get on this
if they want to uh get in you know i'm
not gonna try
uh
and i thought about it like if you had
it like an age group and we could go one
on one with each other um so it's it's
every just go to you know obl hoops.com
uh that's where we have all the
information and for the season we're
going to seven cities
okay we've been to houston we've been to
atlanta our next city is chicago
and basically
there's 32
32 participants in each city
and by and we have a two-day
uh two days where we play games saturday
and sunday by the end of saturday
evening we're down to eight players
those eight players then on sunday play
a single elimination to win ten thousand
dollars
right the top guy wins ten thousand
dollars the top three guys
from that region gets an automatic
invite to vegas for 250 000
where we're gonna crown the ruler of the
court
so once we identify what our motto is
here in north america
then
we're then going to license that model
to other countries no
so they can identify who their ruler is
in their in their own region
and then possibly
you know create an obl olympics
is is the goal so we're
we're building this thing to take it
globally and we have that flexibility to
to be able to do that as a new sports
league good luck great to talk to you
again tracy
thank you dan appreciate you as always
that's tracy mcgrady hall of famer
seven-time nba all-star
ones basketball league take a break
phone calls coming up next what we
learned what's in store tomorrow here
dan patrick show